[music playing]
KARSTEN (VOICEOVER):
I've asked my friend
Lugs to help me take
a look at the Ping
Shin 101's last journey.
KARSTEN: Let's just
go through this
together because there
are a couple things
I need some verification on.
Ready?
KARSTEN (VOICEOVER): As a former
New Zealand Navy engineer,
Lugs knows what it
takes to sink a ship.
So here's what I think it did.
In July 2014, went
past Diego Garcia
and then was
intending to sail home
all the way back to Taiwan.
And in this part right here,
in the middle of the Indian
Ocean-- furthest away from
Ache, pretty far from Colombo,
relatively far
from Diego Garcia--
on the 7th of July, 2014,
it sank here, right?
Yeah.
[music playing]
This is the Australian
Maritime Safety Agency,
and they had a report out that
the Ping Shin 101 suffered
mechanical failure and that
the crew was abandoning
the vessel into life rafts.
It depended what the
mechanical failure was.
KARSTEN (VOICEOVER): Ships
that lose power in heavy seas
can capsize as they drift
broadside to the current.
Yet there's no talk
of that in the report.
KARSTEN: You've had cases
where ships have broken
down with mechanical
failure, and they
just get towed into port.
Yup.
KARSTEN (VOICEOVER): But
there's a second report
from the rescue ship.
KARSTEN: They said that
this ship experienced
flooding in the engine room.
Would one of these
things sink just
because the engine room floods?
Don't you think
that's a bit weird?
It is.
Because they always
use the engine room
as a safe room for
pirate attacks,
because you can
lock it and seal it.
You can lock it down, yeah.
So it would be
the same, right?
It should be watertight.
And why would that rupture?
It would have to run
aground or someone's
done it on purpose.
You mean someone
scuttling the ship.
Yeah.
KARSTEN (VOICEOVER):
I'm sure the rescuers
only reported what
the crew told them,
but why the inconsistency?
[music playing]
KARSTEN: The Taiwanese then
say in their official report
that the Ping Shin 101 grounded
and started taking on water
and sank.
And I mean, this is
where it sank right here,
and in this immediate area,
the nearest landmass--
the nearest place where
there is even a reef
for this thing to ground on--
was in Diego Garcia.
And that's 470 nautical miles.
KARSTEN (VOICEOVER):
Diego Garcia
is a British
territory that's home
to a major US military base.
It seems unlikely that the
Ping Shin would come close
enough to shore to run aground.
KARSTEN: And even if the
Ping Shin 101 grounded,
is it feasible that
they could have
even sailed 470 nautical
miles while taking on water?
Yeah, there's no way.
KARSTEN (VOICEOVER): The
loss of the 101 is important.
It was the key physical
link to the killings.
Normally, a homicide scene
would have forensics--
fingerprints, DNA.
In this case, we
only have video.
And even the ship it was
recorded on has gone.